you to death et squeeze aujourd'hui on
se trouve si on regarde dans les
simulateurs la dernière mise à jour est
sorti aujourd'hui sa tombe parfaitement
bien on est lundi tout recommence à zéro
faisait voix et des nouveautés qui sont
vraiment bien voilà vous allez voir
vraiment je suis un peu mais pas trop un
jeu tease
c'est de la bière avant d'aller en cours
on change de la culotte bien évidemment
voit la petite culotte pedobear elle est
parfaite
alors va accélérer le temps voilà deux
soirs ce que tout le monde aille on
court bien gentiment normalement d'après
mes calculs qui sont toujours faux oui
regardez cette femme bien la geek est ce
son téléphone et du coup tu avais en
plus j'attendais qu'ils aillent là mais
j'ai pas du tout fait ce qu'il fallait
faire on attendra par dessus le pire
mais qu on peut prendre un seau d'eau
voilà comme ça et là on va sur le toit
non bon cette fois je la mets le solo
avant même que les élèves rentrent dans
l'établissement avant fusil de chasse ou
[ __ ] je vais les buts et tu fais quoi
ici mais dégage mais je me fatiguer paru
si tu t'appelles à rayer ces moustiques
leia et han et moi ce petit [ __ ] bref
moi y'en a marre chf à ce modèle est
tout content pour les insectes mais j'en
peux plus de bourgoin caméras embarquées
comme dans les plus grands films
hollywoodiens
taïg ronan il faudrait claquettes [ __ ]
alors ce qui est bien c'est que du coup
une logique moi je crois qu'elle va
dehors à 7h30 pour son téléphone alors
on va et là attention regardez est au
repos la mère d'albert de toi ton
accélérer l contrer très vite plus tard
j'arrive
mais elle veut changer nos soins vers ce
qu'on va la suivre comme ça délicatement
dans l'ombre on va la voir s'échanger
regard des chiffres vraiment les
vestiaires vous voyez pas cru je sais
que vous avez pas contre une crise
jamais faisait pas confiance en moi
oh mon dieu regardez la regarder le
voyeurisme temps mais j'ai du sang sur -
voici que je me change au sémillant
tenue de gym
school swing suite en maillot de bain
voilà qui ont du sang sur mon radar
était au ps m oh la vache
merci pour l'ascension en tout cas ça
m'évitera de me faire attaquer ma vidéo
alors qu'est ce qu'elle fait et cela
vous quoi faut que je m'adapte moi j'ai
du sort butin penser que je peux lui
parler en mois de mai tous les toutes
les données non non ça m'a gêné je suis
désolé je ne peux pas parler maintenant
aux attendes c'est sûr ça qui dépasse la
latence et de la butte en ligue 1 mais
il ya le truc est comme ça où il est mon
faible bise fc bas sont censés deux fois
ce à quoi je peux parler vite of blanc
jouent le jeu trouvera pourquoi quand je
mets un autre uniforme je suis encore
plein de sens c'est un bug regard des
buts à quoi le jeu bête est de savoir
tout le bordel alors c'est mon livre de
julia pas de sens si on a un tout petit
peu dans le dos grâce à ce rapace assure
appartient cette voie catalogue
non mais je suis dirais que j'ai saigné
du nez mais que c'est sa couille dans le
dos à huy une grosse nouveauté aussi
c'est cette poubelle c'est pas une
blague j'ai arrêté on peut la déplacer
comme cela moi j'ai augmenté 0,8 a
annoncé son gré il sort c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi tu es gentil bonjour
madame
ok c'est la pause du midi et c'est là
que j'ai su [ __ ] je me suis seul à
beauchamp vice président iec l'étude un
peu gourmande à lui avec sa petite
claque code tranquillement alors est-ce
que ya les deux autres combats louis jeu
pour les espionner donc logiquement on
peut écrire une petite note délicate sur
un casier juste là vient me voir pour
parler de tes problèmes domestiques à
7h30 sur le toit on va attendre 16h30
dans cette position c'est dangereux
personnes un suppôt très bien et juste
pas venu en fait
[ __ ] c'est le deuxième essai mais j'ai
oublié de placer la poubelle et là où je
suis sûr qu'elle est là haut
j'arrive mon amour bush passé pour la
vidéo souris leur allait tout leur
sourit et tu finis dans là pour elle
[Musique]
pourquoi cette main travers cette
poubelle pour passer cheveux violets
travers cette poubelle et c'est là
attention que ça devient très drôle elle
est là sous les sacs poubelles et de soi
faire on va prôner sacs poubelles et on
va les empiler sur sa petite tête
tiens regarde ce qu'ont fait nos gens
comme toi on les met sous on dirait du
pain ok je viendrai seuil et cette fois
j'ai réussi à faire un saut de sang un
saut en un saut on va à tct le jeune
armel provost et ma [ __ ]
hop là or la bâche et là si on la
rejoint et ce qu'elle est dans son
[ __ ] de pas arrêté de me regarder
comme ça je sais que je voir tout dans
cette vidéo mais laissez moi en paix ok
aujourd'hui est un grand jour parce qu
on est jeudi qu il est 7 heures du matin
qu'on va prendre un tournevis vais les
voir pourquoi oui ces filles y en a une
qui va avoir une envie d'uriner dans
très peu de temps regardez la regarder à
cette garce
excusez moi les enfants tu fais patine
de branlette avec ta main s'te plaît
merci tu prends le seau d'eau tuent
leurs amplis tu lui fout sur la gueule
pendant qu'elle puisse la garce à tuer
teint le truc et tu retires le cache de
l'interrupteur et là regardez regardez
regardez bien le carnage l'apache croda
pas blagueur et là je prends même pas le
corps je m'en fous ya aucune trace rien
c'est le crime le plus parfait de
l'histoire du crime est attaché la
meilleure nouveauté de cette mise à jour
je vous ai gardé le meilleur pour la fin
faire du vélo
oh mais quelle amusement ces fonds on
peut tourner au mail ou un [ __ ] c'est
tellement bien fait celles accueillant
des récits blatter prend tout son charme
jeff of the year game of the century it
so funny to play et 10 sur 10 ha je peux
pas tourner en l'air on peut maintenant
72 coupal et voilà ça dégage chez nul et
voilà les gens se dire quand cette vidéo
surveillance ne les civils à tort
j'espère que ça vous a plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo autant
que vous aimez sempai c'est à dire qu'il
devrait y avoir plus l'infini de j'aime
sur cette vidéo je veux voir le logo
plus infinie sinon je vais me fâcher
très fort et vous savez comment je suis
quand je m'énerve pas viril du tout
merci à leur gardien 70e reviendrons
dans une prochaine vidéo chat et portez
vous bien pis
[Musique]